[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT chapter 3 I'm
Rob this is Jake the show is all about
making dirty arty or argue Morgan a POS
we make them as ugly mean dirty as
possible and we are well on our way
we're also gonna grow out his hair and
see if we can make them overweight Jake
why don't you go to your room all right
in Valentine here and oh do you have
hair tonic Oh should I get hair tonic I
think I do okay all right so how you go
your room so again so again Jake I took
the time do you think I should just
follow the trail to your room for about
two hours straight yeah yeah is this
gonna be the big reveal repeat without
the rinse so this episode we're gonna do
a few things first we're gonna continue
making Arthur overweight and we're gonna
continue growing his hair out as long
and as lush as possible so why don't we
do that for a few days get to our daily
routine and then we'll go out and I have
a list here of what I found to be the
most appropriate attire for dirty Artie
so this requires in order to craft from
a trapper we need to get some legendary
animals under our belt so I have a
listing location we'll see if we can
knock these out in this episode if not
we'll continue into chapter
four so yeah when you go to the store
get some hair tonic
every morning the best is when you go
back here after the hundredth time and
it's our third going the catalog and he
says I'm like oh what do we got here you
know you're getting like you're getting
a shitload of cans Oh
also we should see if raccoon man is in
the bar that's a oh yeah he comes out at
night I think we say he does so well
maybe you'll sleep till night and then
we'll check it's just that time of day
where he shows up nice by some garbage
rude everyone just knows the bed for
another 18 hours this room is so
disgusting
it's so disgusting good morning what
should we do until night then I wasn't
saying is that I wonder I probably have
his hat as in like I have the raccoon
hat but we still need to get a fight
with him it was like 12 rolls I had to
do another one I think that's gotta be
look at how dirty is now cuz he like
prepped for that you like tucked his
knees in and everything
gotta be in here come on baby I'm like a
hundred percent sure I have it because
this is my save let me let me check the
horse and see if the hats there it is
yeah oh you do have it all right we'll
put it on that's that's the new hat yep
alright so what are we doing we hunting
we're hunting why don't we do another
another day or two for that beard okay I
say I should probably get like insanely
drunk surprise as the sheriff hasn't
kicked you out yet I tripped over a
chair that was a bartender I'd be pretty
annoying you just cleared out the whole
bar oh no going to bed oh you should
still be able to sleep right I don't
know dirty are you go to sleep it'll all
go away I try to jump on my horse
[Laughter]
I don't antagonize oh you did say she's
just surrender you want to do some
hunting yeah
legendary alligator okay is that an
salmon yeah well west of Lakai here we
are son done the dirty Artie's old
stomping ground getting the line now are
ya what do you look like well he was
wearing like a raccoon hat eating lots
of biscuits all right oh yeah all right
so maybe engage oh I need to have
completed that mission the other thing
we would want to hunt is wolf pelt and a
goat hide I'm going to kill it with
dynamite I don't know if we'll get a
solid perfect Pelt out of it though do
we need a perfect Pelt we need a a
legendary wolf pelt Pelt but it doesn t
be perfect
[ __ ] at dynamite smoke a cigarette
dirtiest [ __ ] almost bad after walking
out your house this guy would turn right
back around it was any stranger I would
not ask help I heard some I heard it too
oh dude is it the ghost
pull your light out of the way oh there
it is look around dang where was that oh
damn that's a that's an alligator it's
got some red eyes too that's creepy some
dynamite fetch boy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
smarty that as like idiot you can't get
to God oh my god yeah there yeah look at
that it's the ghost
oh that's creepy yeah oh yeah that's
good she led you to good mud okay okay
go ahead to the mountain now Oh what's
this
could we rats here I wanna see if
there's anything to steal first shut up
bean no I don't know here's another one
we might need that for the wolf yeah
that's a dirty already weapon for sure
yep I'd say so
Meg's first new cross is dirty Artie's
path tomahawk maybe not to the face I
don't think I can hit the face but oh
man we should get some like explosive
shotgun shells and stuff too for dirty
arty oh for sure also that's okay
come on bean it's a messy kill but so is
dirty Artie yeah oh these these guys oh
yeah they should attack you on sight
every time so
[Laughter]
you sleep here's a carrot fires killed
me akio fire dog died all right time to
go you're on fire dude stop drop and
roll
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you got no light on upstairs this is
about to get really dark this is about
to get real I should just looted the
Horsham friend yeah
investigating what that loud explosion
no one's there well there's a house up
here we can just Rob what oh so glad we
finally got it
like I feel less guilt and participating
in all this like oh he's just a complete
psychopath trying to get on the roof I
want to take a dive off the roof
boy this episode got real dark yeah
that's fair
I think we I think we kind of plan for
that are we supposed to go find a wolf
oh yes sorry Oh God
awesome dynamite in the back of it sick
ooh we feel like I gotta go yeah yeah
he's trying to race you
oh now you got to kill him I hate these
guys
[Laughter]
you could say he was let down like how
you you kind of masked it like you
didn't really see you at it was my
pleasure
like lead him on like oh that's first
you got here yeah let's race
oh don't mind madam hawk I like that
that's his signature weapon now the
tomahawk yeah Hawking dynamite
[Music]
west of the bridge well it says I'm in
its territory but shouldn't we see like
the symbol of it on the map or something
isn't that usually yeah that's why I
feel like you could keep going like to
what it was saying okay west of the
bridge
I found a dirty Artie's new home easy
[Music]
okay okay I'm sorry
[Laughter]
dirty are you definitely has a split
person
oh yeah you're right that's what we're
looking for
that's oh god it's it dude definitely it
a shotgun oh we didn't pick we can get
really any of good weapons do we there
it is
holy God all right good stuff let's call
it there
wait let me let me jump off the bridge
okay what do you what do you think you
can't go survive I don't know it depends
how deep it is it looks deeper over on
this side
Wow nope they'll survive
all right that will do it
dead red dead we got the pelt though we
got a pail got the pellet we caused a
lot of trouble we did we wrapped up that
quest line with the raccoon head that we
established in the first chapter so yeah
we're doing pretty good
next week we'll probably focus on
growing that hair out a little more and
we'll get a perfect goat hide for one of
these son Danny trapper
pieces of clothing that will make dirty
arty look much dirtier all right well
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you next week thanks Jake see guys
pipe
[Music]